time to conceive now
[Applause]
exactly 20 years ago this morning one of
the most contentious elections in
american history was finally settled
when the supreme court delivered a 5-4
opinion that handed the 2000
presidential election to george w
bush over al gore i'm thankful for
america
and thankful that we are able to resolve
our electoral differences
in a peaceful way
the drama had started 35 days earlier on
an election night that seemed to go on
forever
the focus all on florida the
presidential race
is cracking like a hickory fire here
networks first called the state for gore
nbc news projects that he wins the 25
electoral votes
then took it back what the networks give
us the networks take it away
then called it for bush sip it savor it
cup it
photostat it underline it in red george
bush is the next
president of the united states florida's
a whole game 25 electoral votes there
whoever got those 25 electoral votes was
heading to the white house
before they start the recount they've
got to finish the count
the legal challenges begin immediately
as america became all too familiar with
hanging chads
swinging chads and dimpled chads
florida's punch card ballots that became
the center of the controversy
the image of a judge inspecting one with
a magnifying glass appeared to be on
infinite loop florida stayed the center
of the news universe for more than a
month
as cameras lawyers and protesters
flooded the nation's southernmost state
[Applause]
the florida supreme court ordered a
statewide recount
but that was paused then ordered to stop
less than a week later by the u.s
supreme court
leaving bush in the lead in the end
though gore did get more popular votes
nationwide
he lost the electoral college the first
candidate to do this since
grover cleveland in 1888 tonight for the
sake of our unity as a people and the
strength of our democracy
i offer my concession george w bush won
florida by 537 votes
a margin of 0.009 percent
hard to believe it's been 20 years and
also the past year feels like 20 years
so i don't know where the timing
no doubt about it